my few journalists covering technology
are as influential as Cora Swisher she
co-founded two of the most red Tech news
sites in Silicon Valley has written for
all of America's top newspapers and
interviewed just about everybody who
counts in Tech including Elon Musk Jeff
Bezos Mark Zuckerberg and Tim Cook she's
in London right now to record a live
episode of her award-winning podcast
pivot and she joins me now Connor
Swisher very good to see you this
morning what made you want to come to
London to do this well you know Scott
Galloway who's my part pivot moved here
and we just thought we wanted to try out
these live pivots which we're doing a
lot more in the U.S this year and it
seemed a perfect place to do it we were
at dld we did one in Munich which went
really well so we want to sort of see
what we can do in cities around the
world uh with the brand talking about
various issues in in Tech and media
now obviously last year was a pretty
disappointing one for for Tech investors
what are your Reflections on the sector
for the new year well you know the tech
really ran up high during the pandemic
for obvious reasons everybody was using
it they were home these companies had
the products they needed
um and then there was a natural come
down for the numbers including the fact
that they really staffed up and then the
economy went into a tailspin and so a
lot of these these companies that many
people relied on for the growth in
stocks
um took took the hit when they saw their
earnings off or their growth off or
various things and so it was a natural
thing to happen and at the same time
there's a real transition happening in
Tech in terms of Regulation and all
kinds of things as people try to figure
out what the next big thing in Tech is
now you joust regularly with Elon Musk
has he bitten off more than he can chew
with Twitter
oh I don't know what he's chewing on
it's something I don't know what he's
doing over there um you know I know him
really well I've interviewed him for 25
years or so and I find this this a bit
of a debacle including the carrying of
the sink and it's all been a joke but
it's a lot of money
um a media company is very different
than rockets and cars and he seems to be
using it as more of a toy than an actual
business it's it's already a difficult
business it was before he got there but
he's managed to make it worse which I I
did not think possible but here we are
do you think he's got what it takes to
turn it around and make it profitable
restore its fortunes
um I thought he could he certainly had
the assets including very you know
wealthy friends he had the experience he
had the Goodwill he had a great brand
um the Tesla stock was really high and
now it's been hit very hard for a number
of reasons including this
um but uh but not right now I don't I
don't see them the method to the madness
um they people in Silicon Valley always
tell you that you should focus on that
that he's got a secret plan but I just I
think he's just winging it and that's a
real problem especially around its
current businesses like advertising
absolutely and at the same time
presumably taking his eye off the ball
when it comes to Tesla and SpaceX yes
100 he said you know he says he's there
for a couple of days but you know
they're facing enormous challenges not
the Lisa which is competitors which are
starting to catch up they're not caught
up yet that's for sure Tesla's done a
great job with manufacturing and and
technology so that they're way ahead but
it doesn't mean they're going to hold
that because position
um Second and and the the stuff going on
at Twitter makes a lot of people rethink
buying them because it's so linked to
him there's a demand is off in China a
big important market demand is off
everywhere they're discounting the cars
which they've never done not a great
sign
um you know they're still the number one
but you don't have to stay there
especially when you're gallivanting
around and spending your life trolling
uh trolling journalists and advertisers
and anybody you don't you don't agree
with
quite so I mean what's it like to be on
the receiving end of I mean you get
quite a lot of barbs from these sort of
characters what's it like I don't care I
don't care I don't care that's my job I
don't know do you mind it I don't care
it's you know a lot of them are terrific
Tim Cook is a Class Act every day of the
week and twice on Sunday as we say in
the US
um and uh and most of the others are
fine and we have you know it's good to
go back and forth and disagree uh on
lots of things I've disagreed with
almost everyone I've covered most of
them are professionals and are are fine
with it others don't take it so well and
that's not really my problem it's it's
their own so I just try to ask fair and
and tough questions of them and I think
they deserve that and and smart people
do like smart questions I always
maintain that yeah absolutely now one
thing that was really interesting to me
just uh before Christmas Google and meta
the stake of the US ad Market online has
gone below 50 for the first time in nine
years that's mainly down to tick tock
can that maintain its explosive growth
do you think you know I think it's
facing a lot of headwinds around some
issues around how it's behaving there's
been a lot of journalists of getting
sort of turning on Tick Tock in a lot of
ways and doing a lot of investigative
stuff obviously the link with China is a
real problem for it um and so they've
got to solve that problem especially in
in the U.S where U.S uh politicians as
you can see they just formed a committee
in Congress I don't even know it's
called the anti-china committee I'm not
really clear what's what they're going
to do in the new Republican house but uh
but that it's very it's quite bipartisan
because Biden the Biden Administration
has been trying to figure out how to
deal with China and and the potential of
influence so it could go anywhere and so
tick tock's gonna get caught in the
middle of this and then in general uh
you know these companies use this to to
get advantage in the legislative space
and you could you see companies uh
municipalities cutting the use of tick
tock as a addiction it's just the latest
it used to be Facebook now it's tick
tock um and you're definitely going to
see some sort of legislation around
around chinese-owned companies in the
U.S at least and I don't in Europe that
could happen also but it's certainly
growing steam in the U.S which is one of
its biggest markets absolutely now you
mentioned Facebook there obviously Mark
Zuckerberg is uh pivoted to the
metaverse are these Investments going to
pay off do you think I mean it's it's a
huge bet well he's pivoted to it to it
but the rest of us haven't that's the
problem it's a lot of money he's
spending and I appreciate when someone
takes a big swing but he was sort of
trying to get out of his other business
which is paying all the bills and of
course is seeing also some headwinds
around advertising as you noted and it's
not just Tick Tock Amazon is making
inroads and people aren't and this chat
GPT is going to be there's going to be
some advertising potential Potentials in
search here and so both Google and meta
are going to be under under pressure for
these kind of things what's interesting
is you know the US is not Europe has
been very good about regulation but U.S
has done almost none but the markets are
taking care of themselves in this way in
a really interesting way they can't
really make Acquisitions these companies
because of because of the justice
department or european Regulators or or
Regulators around the globe but at the
same time the other things are emerging
to give them challenges and especially
in a bad economic situation they really
have to try harder to be Innovative
which you know you could say they have
been for large companies but certainly
the next thing is around the corner such
as chat GPT and other things like that
all right Carla I could talk to you all
morning but uh we're out of time I'm
afraid best of luck with the event today
good to see you thank you so much